modesty versus bragging this is a tough
one for people we all think we're being
modest sometimes we don't come across
that way to people how do we know how do
we know people are perceiving us as this
bragger or humble bragging or or the
worst a doood on social media but it's
really
self-serving
yes it's so hard being a super model
that's that's not what you want to do
okay
um you need to have friends that can
give you honest feedback another thing
is you're going to get feedback from the
world if people are leaning in that
means that you're saying something they
want to hear they like you or they're
interested in you if people are leaning
back it means that you're a jerk or
you're boring and I once heard a
Hollywood executive say one of the
biggest sins in Hollywood is being
boring punishable by non
employment so don't be boring don't be a
brager and and you'll know because
people will be turned
off okay so you'll pick up the cues
hopefully hopefully you do if you keep
meeting people and nothing good happens
you should check with some friends and
look into yourself and see what am I
doing what is a personal log
line well to me to me your entertainment
industry brand has three things a
personal log line which answers the
question what do you do it's about 30 or
40 seconds long the answer and you would
use it at a party or a networking event
or if you met somebody in an elevator
and it says who you are it says what you
like to write I work with writers
primarily although work with directors
too um it it highlights what makes you
memorable it's something about you that
the three people standing next to you
can't say because it's your story um and
it's what you like to
write and um it's why you're good at it
without being a jerk um little bit about
you know it's it's very brief that one's
brief there's something called your
personal a story I call it that which is
when somebody says so tell me about
yourself that is a bigger answer than
what do you do and in Hollywood
everybody wants to know what you do but
the truth is they want to know what you
can do for them but you should have an
answer to what do you do um so your
personal a story is the answer to the
question tell me about yourself and
every meeting you have if somebody
doesn't know you they're going to ask
you to tell them about yourself s it's
about a minute and a half to 2 minutes
long the answer and the answer is it's a
chronological narrative of your life
with you as the
protagonist it emphasizes your successes
and What Makes You
memorable and the narrative through line
is where you started what you had to
overcome to get to where you are where
you are and what you want to do next and
it's all
conversational wow okay so how much
oversharing are we doing though with the
overcoming because I know we're in a
space of now being very transparent
about many things don't be too personal
don't and and here's a real bottom line
don't make the person who's listening to
you stop to feel sorry for you cuz that
gets the them out of the flow and you'll
never get them
back good good point there okay so
and we're we're doing this in a fun with
a we're keeping it light it's a fun
twist we're not going to keep it you
know when you say
overcome should I just say and I had to
overcome Bad Hair Days in high school
like keep it maybe or you could say you
know what I grew up in poverty and I had
to work really hard to get somebody to
let me read a book this isn't it of
course and it all depends on how you say
it you know and it really is good to
sprinkle in I was so fortunate you know
I grew up in poverty and nobody in my
family ever thought you could make a
living as a writer but I was so
fortunate because I had a sixth grade
teacher who told me I was a Storyteller
that I could write and so I pursued that
and I got
to but again we're keeping it a beat
we're not yes we're not making the we're
not putting this guilt on the person
receiving our story right guilt or
feeling sorry for you
or doing that okay don't make them do
that okay great to know and and we're
peppering in fun little facts about
ourselves yeah you know I'm Karen I came
here to write the next Little Miss
Sunshine yeah okay I came here to rent
write the next little sunshine and I was
surprised that I ended up having to
clean up disaster areas do you know what
I mean oh that's Sunshine Cleaning
that's a good a good one to no it
absolutely is that's a good one that I
love that Amy ads Little Miss
Sunshine Girl the in the pageants with
Greg caner right right exactly um it
should be engaging now you may not be a
comic you may not be a funny person you
don't have to be
you need to be engaging just make sure
that they're engaged in what you have to
say and say it in a way that feels
authentic you can be passionate about it
and just use your storytelling skills
this time the story you're telling is
about yourself which is just as
important as telling a story in a
script how self aing should we be let's
not be a bragger we don't want to say
yeah it was so hard you know these guys
wanted to date me and things like that
that's going to turn people off but how
much of quote putting yourself down is
also a turn off don't put yourself down
you never need to put yourself down what
you can do if you want to talk about
your accomplishments here's an inside
tip is say I was so fortunate that I won
that contest I was thrilled when I found
out that my script made it on The
Blacklist I was so so excited when I
discovered that I knew Paul Newman
that's such an old reference that I knew
um I would still use that yeah like
thank you um that I knew uh stepen
Spielberg sure you
know that's how you take the sort of
stink off of saying your accomplishments
but don't put yourself down no that is
not attractive think about going on a
date with somebody if they're that's not
self- effacing that's like
being so humble to the point you're
putting yourself down that's not
attractive you're you're in a meeting
and it's like a date
it's I want to know that you think well
of yourself not to the point that you're
obnoxious but that you have confidence
think about a date you want somebody
who's confident being honest about
oneself without being crap yes right um
read the room if you're working in a
nightclub there are things you can say
that you shouldn't be saying in a 10
a.m. meeting with a current
executive um read the room you can push
it a little bit you can be sort of
surprising without being like ew do you
know what I mean or that you offend
somebody don't be offensive that that
should be like the first rule don't be
offensive you
know just don't be offensive sure so
read the room so if you're going into a
um sort of a mixer and it's at a bar
that's one thing if you're going to sort
of a PTA meeting you're not going to be
using the same humor exactly exactly
what's the unspoken Hollywood dress
code casual but professional do not go
into meeting with a suit unless you want
to be an agent nobody wears and even
agents don't wear suits anymore it
should be clean it should be if if if
you're somebody who has interesting
clothes that's great but not something
that's you know like you're going to a
cocktail party this is like a meeting
um casual but know that this is not
really a casual business it looks casual
but it's a business so you know you
might wear a sport coat if you're a guy
or somebody that likes to wear coats
sport coats um but I wouldn't wear a tie
with it no and I also wouldn't wear like
a Shabby T-shirt with a hole in it don't
do that don't wear anything that has
like questionable writing on
it right okay so your mom says hi is
probably proba not a
good and you're not sure the humor is
going to be received at that right okay
but you know what if you're a comedy
writer though you're still taking
yourself seriously enough to wear
something presentable yeah but if you're
a comedy writer and you do have a
t-shirt that's not offensive but it's
funny got make sure it's funny to
everybody right that's true that's true
you can wear that okay good to know and
I say if you're somebody that wears
jewelry wear something really
interesting it's sort of a conversation
St
start